So you remember that I began
the last lecture playing a
poem by Sterling
Brown called Old Lem,
documenting the kinds of
local social trauma and
challenges that African
Americans had to face in a
sharecropping
South. At least,
that's sort of the context
that Old Lem evokes for me.
And I talked about the--the
rise of the NAACP and the
Great Migration, the
forces conspiring it,
and also closed--and then
closed with some vignettes
from The Birth of a Nation
to give you a sense of--sort
of a tactile sense
of a mentality in the
nineteen-teens that reflects
sort of the racial passions
of the age, maybe to put a
poetic turn on it. Today's
lecture's really going to
focus chiefly at the--the
very in--between
1918 and 1920 or so,
essentially, kind of
bringing together all these
different strands of
social, political,
economic tension and
watching how they present
themselves to a national,
international audience. I'm
going to start here in 1918,
move back a bit through
1917, go into 1919, just
so you sort of follow the
trajectory of the
lecture. Also my apologies,
I'm battling a head cold and
I'm hoping that I can get
through all this
without being too congested.
Anyway, this--I'm going
to title this lecture,
I call it "World War I and
the Red Summer." In 1918,
W.
E.
B.
Du Bois, the Director of
Research for the NAACP and
the editor of the
NAACP's journal,
Crisis, you know, the great
leader of the American Negro
Academy, the author of Souls
of Black Folk. Du Bois
writes an editorial. The
editorial is called "Close
Ranks." Now in
writing for the NAACP,
it's supposed to be a
non-partisan organization,
although it had a
progressive political agenda
when it comes to racial
matters. But Du Bois,
over the course of his three
decades or so of continuous
affiliation with the NAACP,
frequently ruffled the
feathers of NAACP
leaders for his independence
and--and essentially
his shifting political
ideologies being--being
articulated in Crisis¸
through these editorials.
"Closed Ranks" is one of the
more famous early ones.
This is an excerpt from it.
So he's talking about
World War I. The U.S.
is not yet involved.
But he's saying, "This is
the crisis--this is the
crisis of the world.
We of the colored race
have no ordinary interest
[coughs] --excuse me-- We
of the colored race have no
ordinary interest
in the outcome.
That which the German
powerrepresents today
spells death to the
aspirations of Negroes and
all darker
races for equality,
freedom and democracy.
Let us not hesitate.
Let us, while
this war lasts,
forget our special
grievances and close our
ranks shoulder to shoulder
with our own white fellow
citizens and the allied
nations that are fighting
for democracy.
We make no
ordinary sacrifice,
but we make it gladly and
willingly with our eyes
lifted to the hills."
"This is the crisis
of the world. Let us,
while this war lasts, forget
our special grievances and
close our ranks shoulder
to shoulder with our white
citizens and the allied
nations that are fighting
for democracy."
This is Du Bois's basic call
to black Americans to invest
their faith in the promise
of American democracy. The
thinking was, by
demonstrating the epitome of
patriotic--the
patriotic act,
risking your life
for your country,
African Americans
would--would--this
demonstration would
certainly translate into
civil rights injustice at
home once the war ended.
Risk your life for the
sake of the country,
and the country will
respect it and honor that
sacrifice. Many black
leaders were angry with Du
Bois, and this is why I sort
of preface this commentary
on the editorial, that this
should not be seen as the
opinion of the
NAACP necessarily,
but Du Bois's opinion. Many
black leaders were upset
with Du Bois because they
didn't think that he was
acting in the best wishes or
the best--in the best spirit
of the race. And while they
didn't think he was quite
acting like Booker T.
Washington, who has just
passed away about three
years at this point, they
were astonished that he
could find it reasonable to
ask blacks--to ask blacks to
forget their special
grievances. We've already
gone over these
special grievances,
of course, listed over
the course of the last few
weeks, a litany of problems
generally associated with
black life in the South,
still largely a southern
population. Those
grievances hadn't changed.
What I want to do today in
laying out this narrative is
talk about these grievances
as they were located in
other places, the
Midwest to a certain extent,
but also more generally the
North. I mean this is the
moment of the migration.
This builds upon that issue
of, you know, what is it
that blacks found when they
landed in these new--new
areas and new cities? Now
as I made clear, I
hope, in the last lecture,
black migration was due
to a range of factors,
but jobs were one of the
most important of these
factors. You know, there's
the political intransigence
of the South, of course,
the terror and lynch law,
but jobs were really one
of the animating--core
animating features. Blacks
migrating to the North or to
the cities in search of
work often burdened social
services--social
service agencies,
who were trying to help out
the needy. Blacks' arrival
in Northern, Midwestern
cities placed extra
pressures on housing,
and blacks' presence
increasingly exacerbated
labor tensions. It's not
surprising.
You think back to the New
York City draft riots with
which I began this class.
Blacks' presence on the
laboring scene created
anxiety among those who were
already working.
In all of these regards, in
overburdened social service
agencies helping out
the poor and the needy,
housing issues,
labor issues,
in all of these regards, you
can see events in East St.
Louis forming into a powder
keg. July 2nd in 1917,
East St. Louis: labor agents
have recruited successfully
thousands of blacks to
work in the East St. Louis's
aluminum factories,
and they were hired,
as I mentioned on
Monday, in this case,
blacks were hired to replace
striking white workers.
These were scab workers.
The striking workers were
furious, of course. The
bosses knew they had a great
card to play, the
race card in this case,
and they used race to divide
the workers. Blacks weren't
allowed in the unions, so
this didn't help matters out
at all, and union organizers
raised the cry of,
I quote here, "Nigger scab"
as blacks were going into
the aluminum factories.
As blacks were going in,
these scab workers going
into the--the factories,
fights break out and
quickly turn from a local,
you know, fistfight or
so to just open violence,
going throughout much of
East St. Louis. The police
force, largely white,
they're not surprised at any
of this happening, but
decide to look the other
way, as whites begin to
assault blacks by clubbing
them, hitting them, stabbing
them. When the dust settles
down, we know that nine
whites and at least forty
blacks died in the riots in
East St. Louis. And I say
at least forty blacks.
If you look at eyewitness
accounts, you start
seeing wide discrepancies of
numbers. And really, what's
unknown is how many blacks
died.
I mean, I'm sure it could
be more whites as well,
but particularly
blacks in this case,
since there are eyewitness
accounts of their bodies
being thrown into
ditches and never recovered,
being thrown into the
Mississippi River and never
recovered. So we don't know
how many people died in the
riots, really. We do
know that thousands of black
families were left homeless
because of these St. Louis
riots. And we also know
that the massacre did not go
unnoticed. Some three
weeks after the riots,
we're talking late
July at this point,
the NAACP organized a silent
march down New York City's
Fifth Avenue. Being
led by muffled drums,
ten thousand men, women, and
children marched from Harlem
to the heart of
Manhattan in dead silence,
simply carrying
banners like,
and I quote here, "Mr.
President, why not make
America safe for democracy?"
or, "Mother, do lynchers
go to heaven?" There's a
couple of images here
from the silent march,
again led by drummers,
not a single sound,
just a simple beat. And
this is what I'll just call
a Men's Auxiliary.
Just the men were marching
separately, carrying banners
about anti--you know,
protesting racial violence.
Dressed in their respectable
best. And in
the same march,
sort of the
Women's Auxiliary,
women and children
marching together,
you know, as far
as the eye can see,
looking up Fifth Avenue,
marching down. The silent
protest, cause no one was
going to hear their cries
out loud, it seemed.
Now East St. Louis,
as it turned out, would
prove to be just the start
of things. Two
years later, 1919,
the country would go through
what has been called the Red
Summer. Now the name didn't
come from the reference to
communism, in this case, but
rather was drawn from the
amount of blood that was
shed. Violence breaks out
in twenty-five cities in a
six-month period in 1919.
Some of the violence
happens in the South.
Some of these riots
happen in the South,
but the majority of the
violence happens in the
Midwest and North. And the
worst riots--in your reading
this week, the sort
of classic book on the
occasion--the worst riots
happened in Chicago in 1919,
in July of 1919. You have
in Chicago a five-day battle
between whites and blacks,
ethnic enclaves of whites
fighting against
blacks. Now Chicago,
as you know from
reading the book,
is a little bit different
from St. Louis--East St.
Louis in this regard, in
that the battle in Chicago
is not really
over labor tensions,
per se. Certainly there are
tensions in the factories,
but not--not like East St.
Louis. The riots aren't
started out of scab workers
trying to break a union,
or being used to break
a union. In Chicago,
the largely--the riots
largely are sparked by
housing tensions.
Now the spark comes out of
the ugly--an ugly racial
incident. A young black
boy goes to Lake Michigan to
enjoy a break from the heat
of the summer. He goes to
the segregated beach and
trudges out into the water.
Now if you know
Lake Michigan,
it looks like an ocean
when you're at the--at the
shore. He goes out into the
water and strays over some
unmarked line. I
can't really say it was
imaginary. People
knew that it was there,
I suppose. He strays
over some unmarked line
separating the races in
the water. A group of white
boys start throwing stones
at him from the shore. He
drowns in the assault.
News about the murder starts
sweeping across
Chicago, and street gangs,
made up of white ethnics,
start roving about with the
stated purpose of defending
their turf. So you already
know the tension's there,
and this might be a spark
they're recognizing of
something really horrible
happening, based on the
violence happening in other
cities. So these street
gangs start to--they're sort
of spread out to defend
their territories. There's
already a history of
first-wave blacks,
you know, the first
to enter into a white,
say Irish
neighborhood, let's say,
or an Italian neighborhood,
to try to find a place to
live, because they were
running out of spaces to--to
live in the so-called "Black
Belt" of Chicago. There's a
history of houses being
firebombed. We'd rather
burn down a house and
risk burning down a block,
actually, than have this
black family move in. There
are all kinds of threats
when blacks try to de facto
integrate white
neighborhoods,
and now things simply
escalated. In the course of
the ensuing--ensuing
five-day riot,
at least forty people were
killed. Two-thirds of them
were black. Thousands
more, over five thousand,
are injured, mostly black,
and thousands of families
are left homeless. Much
like in East St. Louis,
police stood by and let
white mobs attack blacks.
There's some striking
pictures of this in--in
Tuttle's book. Only when
the Illinois National Guard
is brought in does peace
return to the city. It
takes days. But there's a
slightly different element
to this riot, as far as
in sort of the heat of the
moment, not its causative
factors. It's that you had
such a dense population--a
large and dense population
of black enclaves. When
these white gangs start
moving into territories
beyond their own turf,
like the South
Side of Chicago,
it was not uncommon during
these riots for blacks to
set upon them, to defend
their turf. So while blacks
overwhelmingly--overwhelming
ly suffered at the hands of
whites during
the Chicago riot,
one can see a new militancy
in the mentality arising
among blacks. And to
trace this new mentality,
and this actually propels us
into next week's lectures on
the New Negro. To
trace this new mentality,
we need to go back to the
start of World War I and Du
Bois's call to close ranks.
Although black leaders
criticized Du Bois
for his editorial,
many blacks did heed his
call and signed up for
duty. Ultimately, around
three hundred thousand black
men served; half of them
serve in Europe during the
US involvement in World
War I. A call for black
officers is made. This is
a rather bold departure,
and to white
officials' surprise,
is actually answered. But
now we have a problem. How
are you going to train black
soldiers? I've been talking
about the North
here, but as it happens,
this is really a Southern
story at this point,
because so many of the
country's forts and training
grounds are Southern.
Southerners had fears of
"armed negroes," as the
phrase would have been,
particularly Northern blacks
who were now being given
guns, who would
be quick to anger,
they suspected, over how
they might be treated in
southern towns. They
weren't worried so much
about black
soldiers, say from Chicago,
being trained down
in a base in Alabama,
as long as they were on the
base. They weren't so much
concerned about
that. But, you know,
people leave the base and
they might go into the city.
And if they were expecting
to be served at a counter,
or to go in the
front door of a bus,
or go in the front door of a
restaurant and they weren't
allowed, they're worried
about what might result. So
counter to established
military doctrine,
or so I understand it,
instead of training as
entire divisions altogether,
divisions were broken up and
trained in smaller
quantities. They'd be
reorganized overseas
into their proper military
structure, but they
also--and they--these are
black troops I'm talking
about here--weren't always
fighting under the U.S.
flag. They trained with
French troops. They'd be
sent over there to train
with French troops and fight
under the French flag.
So when these black troops
trained in un--in
unorthodox ways in the U.S.
South, in the U.S., get
reorganized into proper
divisions in the
European theater,
the great majority
of them in France,
some fighting
under the French flag,
when they are not in
battle, if they're on,
if they have some leave
perhaps and they go into a
city or a town in France,
they have--an interesting
thing starts to happen, is
that they're treated like
citizens. Black soldiers
in France would tell stories
all the time about--about
having their first true
feeling of liberty when they
were in France. All the
white officers and
government--government
officials, and white offers
under--under command to act
this way, certainly, they
did all that they could do
to prevent it.
They were still being
welcomed by French citizens,
and people coming to
their rescue. Now there are
plenty of stories about
white officers fraternizing
with black
officers in France,
in, say, a local restaurant,
because the white officer
says, "You know, I don't
care what the color of your
skin are--is. You happen to
be--We're fighting side by
side. We're doing the
same kind of job." There's
plenty of those stories.
I'm not going to categorize
all blacks and all whites
working a certain way. But
there were orders issued
about how officers were
supposed to control
black troops. For example,
in 1918, a secret memo was
sent to the French military
mission that was written
by French authorities,
but under pressure and
after approval by U.S.
military authorities, that's
making clear how French
troops should deal with
black soldiers. "The French
public has become accustomed
to treating the Negro with
familiarity and indulgence.
This indulgence and this
familiarity are matters
of grievous concern to
Americans. They consider
them an affront to their
national policy. They are
afraid that contact with the
French will inspire in black
Americans aspirations to
which to the whites appear
intolerable. It is of the
utmost importance that every
effort be made to avoid
profoundly estranging
American opinion."
The directive then goes on
to list a set of conclusions
which I excerpt
briefly here.
The first
conclusion is that,
"we must prevent the rise
of any pronounced degree of
intimacy between
French officers and black
officers." "We must prevent
the rise of any intimacy,
I mean they're talking just
hanging out and socializing
between French officers and
black officers. "We must
not commend too highly
the black American troops,
particularly in the presence
of white Americans." And
another conclusion:
"Americans become greatly
incensed at any public
expression of intimacy
between white women with
black men." That same
specter arises again. Do
not socialize with black
officers. Do not--do not
commend the troops--the
black troops too much,
especially in the presence
of white Americans. And
recognize that Americans get
very uneasy,
"incensed" it said,
at the public expression
of intimacy between white
women, in this case it
would be French women,
and black troops.
It's really profound,
the extent to which
the military and the
government's trying to
preserve its social order,
even overseas. Well,
despite these entreaties,
black soldiers are welcomed
as heroes in France,
and they return to the U.S.
quite reasonably with
expectations that justice
will be theirs, full
citizenship rights,
since they had risked their
lives for the country. For
a moment, in truth, it
actually looked like things
might be better.
When the 369th,
the first black contingent
to fight in the war,
the vision that was
known as the Hellfighters,
the 369th, known also
for its distinction on the
battlefield. When it
returns to the U.S.
in 1919, roughly one million
people watched them parade
from the Lower--from
Lower Manhattan docks,
up Fifth Avenue into Harlem.
The symbolism of--I hope
you already get it. It's no
small irony in the fact
that this is a shift in the
direction from the very
famous silent protest of ten
thousand black
men, and women,
and children, marching down
Fifth Avenue just two years
earlier in the wake of the
East St. Louis race riots.
But now black soldiers
are returning as heroes,
welcomed by a
million people. Change of
direction.
A change of the notion
of who belongs and of
citizenship rights and
possibility. As it turns
out, however, their early
optimism was proven wrong
quite quickly. After a
decline of several years,
over the course
of several years,
the number of lynchings
skyrocket in 1919.
Certainly this might be
in part of--due to the
popularity of Birth of a
Nation and the rise of the
Klan. The Klan really hits
its peak around 1920 to '22,
but it's also quite clear
that 1919 is an important
marker as far as
this is concerned,
because of the over
eighty-plus recorded
lynchings--recorded.
There were certainly
more--of the recorded
eighty-plus lynch victims,
at least ten of them were
returning soldiers, most of
whom were murdered while in
their uniform. So the very
thing that Southern towns
were afraid of happening
manifested itself in
reality, but in a weird--in
a weird sort of way,
and certainly a
miserable sort of way,
Southern towns are afraid,
"What are we going to do
with these Northern black
troops with guns? They
might start shooting at us
and raising hell." Well,
I guess their answer,
out of their anxiety,
was that when these officers
or--officers or troops came
back, whether they were
Northern or Southern,
they felt that now they had
earned the right to walk in
the front door of the
restaurant and to get
served. They felt they
had the right to walk in the
front door of the bus
instead of the back door of
the bus. They felt they had
the right to socialize with
whomever they wanted to.
This was the world they'd
become
accustomed to in France,
and, after all, they had
risked their lives in this
miserable war. And some of
these soldiers were lynched
while in uniform for
doing just such things as
innocuous as talking
back to bus drivers,
talking to white women,
insisting on being served.
This is social control at
the most grotesque level.
Du Bois, you'll remember,
had advocated that African
Americans should forget
their special grievances,
just a year earlier--two
years earlier--a year
earlier, excuse me. And
he sees reports of black
soldiers being
treated like this,
and black
citizens, not soldiers,
being treated like this, and
he realizes he made a grave
error. So he writes a new
editorial called "Returning
Soldiers." And
it says, in part,
of course, "Today we return.
We return from the slavery
of uniform which the world's
madness demanded us to
don to the freedom of civil
garb.
We stand again to look
America squarely in the face
and call a spade a spade.
We sing: This
country of ours,
despite all its better
souls have done and dreamed,
is yet a shameful land.
It lynches.
It disfranchises
its own citizens.
It encourages ignorance.
It steals from us.
It insults us.
This is the
country to which we,
soldiers of
democracy, return.
This is the fatherland
for--for which we fought!
But it is our fatherland.
It was right
for us to fight.
The faults of our
country are our faults.
Under similar circumstances,
we would fight again.
But by the God of Heaven, we
are cowards and jackasses if
now that that war is over,
we do not marshal every
ounce of our brain and
brawn to fight a sterner,
longer, more unbending
battle against the forces of
hell in our own land.
We return.
We return from fighting.
We return fighting.
Make way for democracy!
We saved it in France,
and by the Great Jehovah,
we will save it in the
United--in the United States
of America, or
know the reason why."
I don't want to make too
much of this editorial.
It's an editorial,
after all. Crisis was an
important magazine. It
was very popular. Its
readership is skyrocketing,
there's no doubt about that,
but it is just an
editorial, right? Well,
if you look at a range
of different events,
whether it's
political, social,
economic, violence in
the race riots of 1917,
particularly 1919, if you
look at a mentality that's
being expressed by soldiers
who had fought in the fields
of Europe, trench warfare,
and come--come back with a
heightened sense of
what is rightfully theirs,
quite reasonably of
course, you start to see an
insistence. Some certainly
called it an impatience,
but an insistence amongst
black citizens to actually
have the rights which they
had as American citizens.
Blacks still suffered
terrible discrimination.
They had difficulty securing
jobs or decent housing. But
with the shock of
lynched--lynched soldiers,
more than
anything else perhaps,
the new anger voiced by
leaders like Du Bois,
there was a clear sense that
a new political climate that
was about to appear, that
insisted more ardently than
ever, in fact, that blacks
would have their civil
rights, that they would have
their place at the table,
or else. Now this sentiment
is captured most eloquently
by poet Claude McKay, who
wrote the famous anthem,
If We Must Die, in 1919.
I actually have it on--on
disc, on a--from
iTunes. I could play it,
but this poem is
rather dramatic,
and daunting, and
challenging. And as it
turns out, Claude McKay's
voice is not any of those
things. It sounds really--I
was so disappointed when I
played it the first time,
expecting all this great
drama, and it's kind of very
high pitched and kind of--it
just doesn't--it lacks the
drama. So with apologies to
Claude McKay,
I'll read it myself,
actually. [students laugh]
I can't write like him,
but I can read the--I can
read the poem with a more--a
more appropriate voice, I'll
say. Claude McKay writes If
We Must Die in 1919, and
I mean the timing is no
accident. It's in
response to the violence
that's--that's--that's
being visited upon blacks
with--with a routine that is
sort of almost mind numbing,
violence being
visited upon them by the,
you know, soldiers being
lynched and violence being
visited upon them by
the--the riots in East St.
Louis and Chicago, and
also the persistent sort of
social and psychological
violence that says,
"You do not belong," that you
are an alien in your own land.
Claude McKay writes:
"If we must die, let
it not be like hogs
Hunted and penned
to an inglorious spot,
While round us bark the mad
and hungry dogs,
Making their mock
at our accursed lot.
If we must die--oh,
let us nobly die,
So that our precious
blood be not shed in vein;
then even the
monsters we defy,
Shall be constrained
to honor us though dead!
Oh, Kinsmen! We must
meet the common foe;
Though far outnumbered,
let us show us brave,
And for their thousand blows
deal one deathblow!
What though before us
lies the open grave?
Like men we'll
face the murderous,
cowardly pack,
Pressed to the wall
dying, but fighting back!"
This poem becomes an
anthem for a new mentality,
certainly amongst
artist-intellectuals from
1919 moving forward. One
thing that's important,
and I want to end on this
note. And it's--I confess
it's ending a little
earlier than I expected,
but I want to
end on this note,
because it brings together
many different strands. The
poem is one of
social consciousness,
of course. It's in response
to the violence that--that
Claude McKay has witnessed,
or has been reading about
certainly. But
what you start--what,
what you see
happening at this,
sort of this nexus is
the voice of artists--what
you're going to
see, I should say,
is the voices of artists and
intellectuals rising to the
forefront, and ushering in
this new age of what I'll
just call cultural
insistence on being heard.
That's something we'll be
talking about next week when
we get to the New
Negro Renaissance,
more famously or more
commonly known as the Harlem
Renaissance. This, although
the--I'm getting ahead of
myself here.
The renaissance,
the periodizing of the
renaissance is a complicated
matter. We can look at
this poem in this political
moment, in this
violent moment,
in the moment when the
soldiers march up Fifth
Avenue to throngs, while
some people in that audience
were getting ready to
kill them. A moment of new
awareness, a new racial
voice on the American
scene. I'm actually
going to stop there,
but I'm happy to
take questions,
or if not, we can go our
merry ways. Are there any
questions at all?
Yes?
To what extent
were communists like,
for instance, McKay,
militants? In other words,
did they--did they
condone the use of violence,
or were they just in
favor of protesting?
Well what they're in
favor--what the question is
dealing with, you know,
the link or the connection
between communists and
militancy and advocacy of
violence. I think it's--a
simple way to put it is that
what communism is in a state
of profound flux. It's just
being articulated, you
know, at this moment,
and you're going to see more
of that going through the
1920s into the 1930s.
Oops.
But the--so whether some
advocated--some communists
advocated violence, some
advocated something else,
it just depends on the--on
the individual. McKay and
others, you know these
people who traveled to
Russia and then
the Soviet Union,
trying to find answers, you
actually have--and I'm glad
you asked it, because I
won't be talking about it so
much in this class, I don't
think--you have throughout
the 1920s, thirties,
and into the forties,
mostly in the 1930s,
certainly the rise of
pop--the popular rise of
Communism amongst black
Americans. I'll say
something about that later
on.
But you actually have a
large number of African
Americans,
especially professionals,
who become
card-carrying communists,
but never talk
about it loudly,
because they'll lose their
jobs. A lot of teachers,
especially, and
certainly many more who were
sympathetic to Communism.
Now were they sympathetic to
it because they advocated a
class struggle? For many of
them no, because they were
occupying a niche in black
America that accrued
benefits. You know,
these were the middle class
in many ways. But were
they--they were
seeking civil rights.
And this is something
I will come back to,
is that you look at the
popularity of the Socialist
Party and the Communist
Party amongst African
Americans. It wasn't
necessarily because they're
advocating the overthrow of
the capital machinery. It's
that they were
advocating, in the U.S.,
a version of Communism, full
civil rights for African
Americans, and that was,
that was the thing. That
was the quest for
African Americans,
citizenship.
Yes?
What was the readership of
poems like Claude McKay's in
the editorials?
You know, it's always
hard to gauge the readership
of--of, well of anything,
and--and especially in this
case, and also like the
Chicago Defender and the
editorials that I mentioned
before and that you saw in
the--that you have
in the documents,
because a lot of these
documents will be read by
communities. And I mean
that literally in the sense
that, you know, you might
have the paper coming down
and ending up in a
barbershop or a black public
sphere--space, black public
space--space where you don't
know how many people are
actually literate there
necessarily. These things
are being read out loud,
they're being
passed along, they're,
you know, going
from the barbershop,
to the beauty parlor, to
the dining room table. So
readership, we
don't--we don't really know,
but when I talk about Claude
McKay's If We Must Die
having importance, it
becomes an anthem. And in
that way, in that way, I
mean to imply that it was
known. Whether people
know all the words or not is
something different,
but they know about it,
and they know this is a call
to a new kind of mentality
that they're ready to
embrace as well. I mean,
something they
thought was right there,
when the 369th
walked--marched up to,
what I should have said, to
white and black applause,
going up to--up, up in
Harlem. These were national
heroes. But on local--and
when it came down to local
matters, they were treated
quite differently. But
we'll see in next week's
reading interesting terrain
about--around that kind of
question of who's following
who. Overlapping this, and
I'm getting into Monday's
lecture a little bit, is
the rise of Marcus--Marcus
Garvey's Universal Negro
Improvement Association. Do
I talk that much about
Monday or not? I don't
know. But that--that is
incredibly popular during
this period and that's a,
sort of an X factor that's
not mentioned for the
sake of clarity in today's
lecture. I'll clean that
up a bit on Monday. Yes?
You were talking
about a greater state of
egalitarianism in France.
Yeah.
And I--I understand why in
the--the context of World
War I that made sense, when
France was so desperate,
but was France a much
more egalitarian society
considering they'd had these
brutal colonial endeavors,
you know in Algiers and in
the several different cities
in the world?
But it wasn't in
Paris. I mean,
I mean talking--the
question's about,
you know, the what's
the reality versus the
perception--the perception
versus the reality of
egalitarianism in France,
and thinking about France as
a pretty vicious
colonial state,
especially in Francophone
Africa. There's no doubt
that there's the--the mixed
reality there. You have a
lot of black soldiers going
over to France. And what I
didn't mention, a
lot of them stayed.
It's like, "I'm not going
back." And you have during
this period the rise of an
incredibly popular movement,
I mean this
American musical art form,
jazz, becomes incredibly
popular in France,
especially Paris,
during that time.
Jazz musicians, dancers,
et cetera--and I'll be
mentioning a bit of this
this time next week--are in
the Parisian scene and
are incredible stars,
and just don't
want to go back,
because they know they're
going to be treated horribly
back--back home. There is
a--a rising awareness of
what's actually happening in
places like Algeria during
the same period, especially
as some of the intellectuals
start coming to Paris and
interacting with African
American
intellectuals and artists,
and interacting in
very curious ways,
in very complicated ways.
This actually becomes more
prominent as you head
towards the Second World
War, and the rise of
anti-colonialist movements.
We aren't quite sort of
there yet as far as it being
articulated. But there's
always the difference
between what's happening
in the center and what's
happening in the provinces,
about what--what reality
looks like.
Anything else? Okay,
have a lovely
day. Thank you.